The Joe Rogan Experience Brett Favre is
in deep [ __ ] and what did he do just
like a welfare fraud thing yeah he was
friends with the governor of uh
uh I don't know which Governor it was
what's that
yeah yeah Winston because he went to he
he went to Mississippi Southern
Mississippi University or some college
and his daughter's going there and she's
a volleyball player and they needed a
new gym or like a stadium for volleyball
games and so he talked to the governor
and they arranged to siphon money out of
a out of a fund that was like a welfare
fund meant to feed poor people
and they took like six million dollars
out of it and built a stadium and
there's a whole text chain just I mean
plain as day he even says at one point
like is there any chance we're going to
get caught for doing this oh boy and the
governor is like nah don't worry about
it we're good oh no yeah and I mean you
think about a guy like that what is he
making 20 million dollars a year if you
want to buy if you want a [ __ ]
volleyball stadium for your kid you got
that money you got it
that's so crazy yeah
and he had a legacy that's like a
jailable offense isn't it
um
I mean is that one of those I mean that
seems like one of those ones that
wouldn't just be a fine it seems like it
if you're stealing from welfare yeah
like that's the kind of stuff people go
away for right well especially because
one of the millions of dollars went
directly to him oh yeah so it's like
some of it went to the school and one of
the millions went directly and he's
already so wealthy yeah imagine how much
money he would pay to not have that
happen hmm
yeah like this Scandal was about to go
down right now and people found out like
how much would you pay to not have that
happen yeah
definitely more than a million oh yeah
he'd probably give you like two million
shut the [ __ ] up well he's probably he's
probably worth 30 or 40 million he'd
probably give you half of that to not
tarnish the reputation forever and not
only that but might wind up in jail yeah
you know there's a problem that needs to
be addressed whenever it comes to uh
football players Fighters Combat Sports
athletes is that uh people with CTE
oftentimes have very poor decision
making
it's very uh complex because everybody's
version and and severity of C CTE is
different
but one of the side effects of uh having
too many concussions is you become very
impulsive and you start doing uh risky
things risky behaviors sometimes people
get addicted to substances and and
gambling and a lot of wild [ __ ] and it
comes from like your brain being rattled
like it's just not working right like
you have all sorts of impulse control
makes sense so I think risky things like
this might have been exciting you know
like you should have obviously morally
known that's not the thing to do but
there's something I think
for guys that have been hit in the head
too many times like risky things like oh
they just want if you're a guy and
you've got all your jollies out of
playing football
I mean you got all your jollies out of
being this badass [ __ ] quarterback or
some badass running back and the amount
of excitement
on Super Bowl day must be
unfathomable to us mere mortals yeah to
us mere mortals the the excitement of
being on that field and knowing that
millions of people are going to be
watching around the world millions and
there's 50 60 000 people in that place
screaming their [ __ ] heads off and
you're playing football at the highest
level of the world
[ __ ] man you want a guy like that to
just go back to normal life after he's
been hit in the head 50 times hey I got
my own mower now yeah right that guy is
gonna start gambling and going to [ __ ]
houses or starting Coke and punching
traffic attendance look he's he's
[ __ ] bored out of his mind look at
Lenny dykster man [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] how about [ __ ] I mean think about
how excited you are to go to a Super
Bowl think about the excitement level
that person has and now you're the guy
in the center of it and you got the
possibility if you win of making an
extra million in your bonus yeah
whatever else there's so many factors
going into that